in this video i'm going to talk to you
about the 28 ways to stay poor and the
reason i'm framing it that way is
because charlie munger my personal hero
had a seminal talk that he gave multiple
times on how to live a miserable life
and the reason he gives it that way is
that he believes in a process called
inversion thinking which is where you
solve problems in reverse so for example
if you want to have a good marriage
rather than asking the question how do i
have a good marriage you ask the
question how would i destroy my marriage
and then you list out all the ways to
destroy your marriage and then you do
the exact opposite of that and what's
interesting is that our brains are much
better at finding problems than they are
finding solutions and so we do is we
harness this innate ability that we have
to find the problems and then after
finding every possible problem we can
imagine every threat imaginable which
evolutionary we're designed to look for
then flip that in reverse to find our
solutions all right and this is a
process of thinking that i've applied to
business i've applied it to merit i've
applied to a lot of different aspects in
my life and i would and i would
encourage you to do it as well but in
this video i'll talk about the 28 ways
to stay poor hey and stay tuned to the
end of the video because at the very end
i'm going to give you the reverse of
these the 28 rules
of how not to be poor i'll take all of
these things and i'll reverse them for
you in one hard-hitting blip that you
will not want to miss all right if you
don't know who i am my name's alex for
moses i own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies that deserve 100
million a year and have nothing to sell
you i make these videos because i have a
lot of fun doing it and i hope you enjoy
them as much as i enjoy making them for
you all right so the first one this is
one of the best ways to stay poor and as
a result by the way side note this
entire little mini thread here got over
5 000
shares on my twitter uh and so that is
why i decided to make this video because
it seemed like a lot of you guys like
that okay so the first and best way to
stay poor is to start tomorrow so
whatever it is that you want to do
whether it's losing weight saving money
starting that business whatever it is to
start tomorrow all right so that's the
best thing you can do to stay poor is
just start tomorrow okay the next one is
to read lots of books and then do
nothing all right because it's one of
the you know lots of people talk about
reading books and i see people all the
time that i've seen for years in the
exact same position posting oh yeah i'm
reading 52 books this year that's my
commitment instead of reading 52 books
maybe just read one book and actually do
something about it crazy i know number
three take advice from poor people on
how to be rich all right so think about
that for a second a lot of us surround
ourselves or at least i did when i was
starting out surround ourselves with
people who are very poor and we listen
to their advice on how to be rich and
they have no idea what they are doing
and we also listen to their judgment on
why our idea is stupid even though they
are poor so what would they know so
number three take advice from poor
people on how to be rich number four
this is a big one pick a spouse who will
make you feel guilty for working all
right so you have your dreams you have
these things you want to pursue but this
person is saying you shouldn't do that
you need to be doing x y z blah blah
blah and then you feel like you need to
compromise your dreams for that person
the problem is that you put your power
of your destiny in their hands and
you're asking for permission instead of
support right because the end of the day
if you don't accomplish your dreams and
you did it because of them who do you
think you're going to resent so you owe
to yourself and you owe it to your
marriage to hey pick people who are not
who are going to support you in your
dreams even if they don't necessarily
agree right but more easily not put your
power in somebody else right number five
fail once quit forever all right so as
soon as you do actually start to decide
doing something you fail immediately and
say oh i guess this isn't for me i guess
success isn't for me i guess business
isn't for me i guess sales isn't for me
i guess whatever the thing is isn't for
me because you failed once but it's
because we have we have an incorrect
view of failure because failure is a
necessary part and the thing is you
learn from failure and so it's either
you win or you learn but that is the
fifth thing you want to do if you want
to stay poor forever number six is think
that the world is fair
so a lot of us are get you know
especially me earlier on like i would
complain i'd be like that's not fair
this is fair it shouldn't be this way
blah blah blah blah and the thing is is
that all that complaining that i did did
nothing at all whatsoever did nothing
and so the thing is is there's no
activity that comes from blaming your
circumstances which just so happens to
be the seventh one
of how to stay poor is blame your
circumstances and complain all right
complaining about things that you cannot
control and the thing is is like these
sound so obvious but think about these
in reverse again so if the if the
contrary of thinking the world is fair
is assume the world is fair it's unfair
excuse me assume the world is unfair and
then act accordingly instead of blaming
your circumstances you think your
circumstances for who you are and what
they gave you you are who you are
because of the [ __ ] that you have gone
through right there's there's a saying
your mess is your message and i think
it's a very it's a very beautiful saying
because how sad would it be to wish to
have a life of ease and comfort because
strong character is built through hard
times and so if we want to have strong
character we basically must have a hard
life for periods of time or for seasons
and so we can't lament the thing that
creates the outcome you can't lament the
heat and and that the beating of the
hammer to to strengthen the steel right
they go one in this third they go hand
in hand and so we just have to accept
them for what they are and and as for
complaining i think you can just accept
and move on so number nine i covered
three there number nine expect the
government to save you all right that's
a great way to stay poor expect the
government to save you or even say
expect other people to save you the
reality is no one's going to save you
except for you and a lot of times many
people have spent their entire lives
waiting around for someone to save them
and still stay poor number 10 value the
opinion of others over your own it's an
excellent way to stay poor you think
everyone else's opinions matter more
than yours and i'll give you a secret
that it took me you know making a lot of
money to then realize which is you are
successful the moment you say you are
crazy right like you are successful the
moment that you decide you are
successful there are people who are
billionaires who don't feel like they
are successful and there are people who
have almost no money and absolutely
think they're an amazing success and the
thing is is that they are both right
it's our choice and i can promise you
that if you try and give yourself a
number you will just move the goal post
i promise you that from the depth of my
soul you will move the number and make
something else the new goal and once
that once i am rich then whatever but
it's a when then fallacy it doesn't it's
not true so you can accept and you can
become
successful today because if you look at
yourself compared to people in a much
worse off scenario they would love to
have your life and so you just need to
decide for yourself if you are
successful the thing is success is a
process rather than an outcome and so
you can be successful in that you are
living your values of pursuit that can
mean success if you choose to define
that way so number 11 way to stay poor
avoid discomfort all right a lot of us
you know we have new things you have to
take risks you have to learn things and
it's uncomfortable because you will suck
right of course you will suck it's
normal to suck but people avoid
discomfort because they don't want to go
through that and it's so silly the
discomfort that they're feeling is the
judgment they impose upon themselves
about not being good at something
they've never done before how insane is
that very and that's why humans are also
kind of insane when you think about the
things that we do the things that we
think and so great way to stay poor is
to avoid discomfort of all kinds you
also guarantee the number one discomfort
which is that you don't accomplish what
you want in your life 12 how to stay
poor tolerate mediocrity from yourself
and others all right so as you start to
grow if you're growing you know a small
business or even in the workplace if you
tolerate mediocrity from others you will
get more mediocrity and people over time
will just degrade and get worse and
worse over time rather than the reverse
of that of thinking like i will only
tolerate excellence and anything below
that is intolerable if you think about
the best leaders and the best ceos the
most successful people of all time they
have this innate trait right for lack of
terms they're ball busters right they
hold a standard that and here's the
catch that they themselves stay above
which means you must raise your own
standards so that you can model what it
looks like for other people around you
to hold themselves right the best like
most people need to be led most people
need a model and they can see that right
and you're you're leading by example and
so best thing to do to stay poor
tolerant mediocrity from yourself and
others 13. how to stay poor make
promises break promises
so you make promises to yourself made
promises to other people and you both
you destroy your reputation with other
people and that's a terrible thing and
it takes a long time to fix that but the
one that's the hardest one to fix is the
reputation you have with yourself you
make promises to yourself and you break
promises to yourself because the thing
is you're the only one who's holding you
accountable and i think a different
version of happiness in my opinion is
respect for oneself and i think your own
respect is the hardest to earn because
you know how hard you could have pushed
you know if you could have gone for an
extra mile you could have showed up to
the gym more times you could have eaten
better you could have made more cold
calls you could have done more reach
outs you could have made more content
you could have actually done a
left a nice note for somebody on your
team when you when you were too tired to
do so you could have over delivered on
the product you could have made a better
version of that video and you decided to
put it up anyways even though you knew
it wasn't as good as it could have been
and so you make promises to yourself and
then you break promises to yourself and
you lose respect in the process it's an
excellent way to stay poor number 14
wait for perfect conditions all right
this is a great one great way to stay
poor is uh it's one of my favorites you
gotta wait for everything to be
perfectly aligned for you to be
successful and here's the secret there
are never gonna be perfect conditions
and here's what's even crazier if you
need perfect conditions to be successful
the moment the conditions change you
will stop being successful so you might
as well start when the conditions are
their absolute worst because it means
that they will only get better from
there and if you can prove success when
things get bad when they get bad again
which is guaranteed you will still
remain successful because you have
learned how to do it in this time in
this circumstance make sense great
reason do not wait for perfect
conditions
15. prioritize looking rich over being
rich this is a classic one of poor folks
in general i get the the loving amount
of troll comments that i get from the
fact that i'm in my mama's basement and
wearing a wife beater and wearing a nose
strip right must mean that i am poor of
course right because you confuse looking
rich with being rich right just silly
you can just google my name and just put
uh private equity and uh at gym lunch
and american pacific group and you can
see what we sold to our businesses for
so the point is
you have to prioritize being rich which
means spending less for a long period of
time because you are not valuing the
opinion of other people over your own
which because you respect your own
approval more than that of other people
you have to be willing to die to the
opinion of others rather than dying to
the opinion of yourself and i mean that
it's real [ __ ] stop trying to look rich
be willing to look poor all right i know
this contrary to like dress the part and
all that stuff but like the thing is is
like you've got to be real to you or
you'll be real to no one that's a
promise number 16 avoid working on what
matters most all right this is a great
way to stay poor is that you work all
day long you're busy you're full of
activity you're doing stuff and nothing
important moves forward because the
nature of speed is not about activity
the people who are the richest in the
world aren't doing the most stuff
they're doing the right stuff right
they're making sure better stated making
sure the right stuff gets done in
general whether or not it's them or
someone else and so it's looking at the
many things that you can or could do and
picking the very few that are the ones
that move the needle the most and
typically they're the ones that you do
not want to do and you are
procrastinating on and you can probably
eliminate all the stuff that you that
give you the mental masturbation of
getting stuff done without actually
moving the ball forward towards your
goals so it's a great way to stay poor
it's just keep doing stuff that does not
matter 17. say you're going to do
something and then don't do it this is
just like making and breaking promises
to others himself but this one is
actually just like that so take that 18.
this is a really good one great way to
stay poor is do what everyone else is
doing right because if you're doing what
everyone else is doing most people are
not in the one percent if you want to be
in the one percent you can't do what 99
of people are doing which is hard for
people which is why you can't value
their opinions because again talking to
poor people about how to get rich is a
great way to stay poor right they have
no idea and so you can't look for their
approval on what you are doing or model
what everyone else is doing because
everyone else is poor why model them
right think about it number 19 do your
best not what it takes because the
reality is a lot of times your best may
suck and what is required is what is
required and that may be beyond you
which means you must become better so
that your best is beyond what is
required because the number of people
who say well i tried my best universe
doesn't give a [ __ ] the marketplace
doesn't give a [ __ ] your boss doesn't
give a [ __ ] what they care about is what
is required and so what you have to do
is figure out what is required and then
if you are incapable of doing it be
better and do it for long enough that
would be unreasonable for you not to be
good and then your best will surpass
what is required and you will become
better in the process but if you don't
do that it's an excellent way to stay
poor it's just keep doing your best and
giving yourself paddling back and say i
tried 20. talk more do less post about
your goals post about your affirmations
spend all day doing routines and stuff
of getting prepared to work and actually
do very little all right it's a great
way this is one of the favorite ones
especially in the the internet community
people love talking about how much
they're working rather than actually
getting [ __ ] done so i would advise you
to rather than spend all this time
preparing to work and creating
superstitions and routines around the
things that you think you should do in
order to maybe potentially get something
done start with the doing because
sometimes the doing just needs done all
right
21 start something new today start
something new tomorrow repeat great way
to stay poor do stuff try something try
something else try something else try
something else always leave half-built
bridges right you never complete
anything you start just keep starting
new things because it's exciting and
it's new and you have what is called
uninformed optimism because as soon as
you jump into the new thing you realize
that it will take work and the things
that were awesome about it also have
downsides which is the work that is
required to be good and as soon as you
realize that is work you go through the
change cycle you go uninformed optimism
to informed pessimism and then you go
through the valley of despair and this
is where everyone then jumps to the next
opportunity and they just do this
forever and they just never achieve what
they want so it's an excellent way to
stay busy and poor all right just keep
trying new stuff and never see anything
through okay number 22 believe what
other people think about you more than
what you think about you all right it's
a great way to stay poor i think it's
just it's easily stated there so i'm not
going to belabor the point but that's
what you need to do to stay poor just
keep believing what everyone else thinks
about you and not what you think about
you excellent way to do it number 23 way
to stay poor make a mistake then
wait repeat the mistake do it again and
again and again and you've probably seen
people who stay stuck in their life like
this like they keep dating the same
person they keep making the same
business mistake that keeps getting the
same bad partnerships whatever right or
they keep trying to do something that
stopped working and they keep doing it
over and over again because they think
that for some reason that's gonna work
somehow or they just don't have the
wherewithal to realize they keep making
the same mistake and so if you keep
doing the same stuff you're going to
keep getting the same outcomes right
like we kind of know this but the thing
is is that people still do it it's like
well whatever you're doing right now has
gotten you to being poor so don't do
that right and when i say poor poor can
be whatever you want it to be you could
be a billionaire and be poor it might be
whatever whatever that amount is it's
not as much as you want it to be right
which of course gets into the deep
things of like maybe you should decide
not to want it to begin with and then
whatever we won't get into that number
24 be replaceable all right this is a
great way to stay poor because if and i
i heard this from navarro kind of like
it a lot which is if you can if you can
get a degree to do the job you're never
going to be on wealthy doing it because
everyone can do it right and so you have
to be able to learn things that other
people can't do right and that therein
makes you irreplaceable or less
replaceable right at the very least less
replaceable you want to be replaceable
by a marketplace of people lined up
behind you ready to take your job and do
it for less all right because they're
also poor and they are willing to do it
for life which is a terrible way to do
business it's also an excellent way to
stay poor though do what everyone else
is doing do it for less unless you have
an operational strategy which is you
know like walmart and whatever and
that's probably not you right now so
number 25 way to stay poor find
something that works dear god find
something that works and then stop doing
it
think about it
how many of you have needed to make
money last minute you had to pay payroll
you had to pay taxes you had to some
bill unexpected you know surgery iphone
whatever right some bill comes up and
you need to pay for it and you find a
way to make the money because if you're
watching this video you're still alive
right so you found a way to you found a
way to pay for it what did you do there
when you needed to make money you heard
something messed up
you were willing to make money and you
had the ability to make money when it
was for someone else and not for
yourself
think about that
you had the ability you knew what to do
and you just chose not to do it you
stopped doing it as soon as you paid
someone else's bills because you were
willing to pay other people's bills not
your own interesting which leads me to
one of the most retweets i had recently
which is most people know what to do to
achieve their goals most people do know
what to do people are like i don't know
how to lose weight i'm like yeah you do
stop eating [ __ ] and move you know how
to you know do that you want to make
money start making calls start reaching
out to people start promoting the thing
that you are trying to sell
not i mean not complicated i got this
thing do you want to try it no cool talk
to somebody else got this thing you want
to try it no cool call somebody else
right it's not it's not complex it's not
complicated but people just don't do it
it's because they're not willing to do
it right and so
excellent thing to do find something
that works so a lot of you do know
something that works and then stop doing
it number 26 we're rounding off we got
two more
hire dumb people excellent way to stay
poor and have a bad business all right
really really highly recommend it's also
really good for if you have a job too if
you have the ability to hire people hire
dumb people it's just it's just a great
way to make your life miserable there's
very few ways that are better than this
one like if you just want to be
surrounded by dumb people just hire
people i mean just hire people don't run
you you know i mean and um you'll you'll
feel good but you'll be poor and so
don't do that
number 27 this is a huge one that i see
all the time for staying poor it's a
really good strategy it might be one of
the top ones on this list assume you are
always right how many people here right
you're watching this know someone who
always
just think they're right and they're not
successful they get advice from somebody
who might be successful more successful
than them and they're like no that's not
going to work for x y and z because they
assume they're always right they assume
they know everything well if you know
everything then why aren't you achieving
what you want hmm and i will tell you
this from the people that i've met who
have been far ahead of me they have a
voracious desire to learn and a
voracious interest in learning from
anyone and every single possible source
they can and those people have the
humility to say that everyone knows
something that they don't know and so in
that way they can learn of them which is
i think an emerson quote if you cannot
learn
then what's the point so you give
yourself zero advantages like there's no
way that you can learn from other people
if you think you're always right and i
know this sounds [ __ ] obvious but a
lot of you guys do this
why like you'd rather be right than be
rich and it's silly but it's an
excellent way to stay poor so that's why
it's number 27 and then the last one and
this is the simplest of the economics
around it i'm just gonna drive this baby
home is
make money period spend more than you
make and the beautiful part about this
is that it doesn't matter how much you
make if you spend more than it you can
be poor which is why this is such a
great one it's a great way to stay poor
it doesn't matter how much you increase
your income just spend more than you
made right go into debt and adjust your
lifestyle to your new income at all
times or rather above your income so
that you can always stay poor no matter
how much money you make it's just an
awesome way to stay poor and so i highly
recommend doing that all right um just
and honestly the more you can do it the
more you can outspend your income the
poorer you will be and so again highly
recommend it and it sounds silly but you
know a few people like right now i think
it's like the bottom 50 of america like
doesn't have any savings and what's
crazy is that like you can you can
control like these these things are
controllable like you can always
downgrade your lifestyle but the thing
is you care more about the opinions of
others than you do about your own right
you care about more about looking rich
than being rich right all these things
and that's why all of these things go
together and so to wrap this up the
reason that inversion thinking is so
powerful is that we can use our brain to
find threats more easily than we can
find solutions and so if we think about
your business career or you think about
your marriage or you think about your
body or you think about whatever it is
your money goals think about the ways to
destroy it i just gave you 28 different
ways that you can be poor when you
reverse them and you make those the
rules for living that you have
then what happens is you succeed by
accident because you avoid the pitfalls
because the thing is if you don't make
many mistakes you succeed without trying
because all you're doing is just
focusing on just not making these stupid
mistakes that most people do right if we
if we were to reverse these and this is
what i'm going to hit this with hard
enjoy we're hitting it right now start
today read books do the stuff that's in
the books take advice from rich people
on how to be rich pick a spouse who
makes you feel awesome about working
fail once try again think the world is
unfair and act accordingly never blame
your circumstances thank your
circumstances for making you who you are
instead of complaining do something
expect no one to save you except for
yourself value your opinion over those
of other people seek out discomfort
tolerate nothing but excellence make
promises keep promises wait for the
worst conditions wait for imperfect
conditions and act anyways on what you
want right avoid working on the stuff
that doesn't matter work on the things
that matter most ignore the rest say
you're going to do something and then do
it do what no one else is doing do your
best
and make it above what it takes to be
successful talk less do more start
something new today and keep at it until
you are good do it so long that it would
be unreasonable for you to be bad don't
believe what other people think about
you more than what you think about
yourself be irreplaceable find something
that works and don't stop doing it keep
doing it until you're bored out of your
mind because you're so good at doing
that thing that worked hire smart people
assume that you were always wrong and be
willing to learn and make money and
spend less than you make and that is the
28 rules of poverty flipped on its head
and you can make your own conclusions
about where that'll take you i love you
mostly nation keep being awesome i'll
see you guys next video bye